The Wire is a special show.
Few television shows inspire a stack of books
about it’s creation and themes, even fewer
inspire a collection of college courses examining
those same things, and only one has inspired
sitting the president of the united states
to invite the show’s creator to the White
House for a conversation.
What is it that makes this show so special?
In this video, part one of my series about
The Wire, I’ll be exploring why The Wire
is brilliant, without spoiling the plot, so
even if you haven’t seen the show yet, you
can learn why it’s so special.
Not A Cop Show
The
Wire is not a cop show.
Yes, a series of police wiretap investigations
is the spine around which the show is constructed,
but The Wire starts out, at the very least,
as a subversion of the standard cop show,
and only become more from there.
Where in most police dramas the moment of
chasing and arresting the suspect is the dramatic
climax, these are often the very moments The
Wire skips over.
But The Wire is much more than a subversion
of the classic police drama.
Season One establishes a failing, corrupt
institution, the Baltimore
Police Department, and a band of rebels within
its ranks that are fighting desperately to
eek out any semblance of “good police work.”
But what our detective are up against, is
not a clear cut set of “bad guys” but
a rival institution, a Baltimore Drug Gang,
made up of real humans.
An institution complete with its own set of
rebels, hoping to swim against the system.
Each of the following seasons adds another
layer of the city, examining the institutions
above and below the two featured in season
one.
Season Two adds in the decaying port economy
and labor unions, season 3 sees the addition
of political realm, season 4 adds the school
system, and season 5 journalism.
If all this sounds a bit dry and academic,
it certainly is when placed beside your average
episode of Hawaii Five-0.
The Wire doesn’t try to
grab and keep your attention.
It requires it, and if you give it your attention
it will reward you.
But it’s also entertaining, the show tells
this story of the city and it’s institutions,
not through dry exposition about the institutions
but through the individual stories of an incredible
cast of engaging characters within those institutions,
fantastically acted, and brilliantly written
by a team dedicated to realistically portraying
the city of Baltimore.
All The Pieces Matter: Good Writing
The Wire has a great acting, cinematography
and sound design, but what stands above everything
else, the key element, is the writing.
The Wire reaches a bar for quality of writing
reached by few television shows.
Write what you know, is a basic directive
commonly issued to writers, and few TV writers
have exemplified this idea as well as show
creators David Simon and Ed Burns.
David Simon was a reporter for the Baltimore
Sun for 12 years.
He covered crime and the police department
extensively, and eventually went on to write
Homicide: A Year on the Killing Streets and
The Corner: A Year in the Life of an Inner-City
Neighborhood both of which Simon adapted for
television.
Collectively all this can be seen as nearly
two decades of writing experience closely
focused on the topics that would largely be
covered in The Wire.
David Simon spent years examining the worlds
The Wire explored before one episode was even
written.
While he was still a journalist Simon developed
a relationship with Ed Burns, who spent 20
years working as a Baltimore City Police,
before joining forces with David Simon to
write The Corner.
If Simon had spent 20 years reporting and
writing about the topics that The Wire examines,
Ed Burns spent 20 years living them.
Including spending time as a public school
teacher in Baltimore, direct experience, on
which much of Season 4’s story is based.
As Police Detective and Crime Journalist turned
Television Writers, these two were interested
in far more than making another cop show to
entertain the masses.
They aspired to put a contemporary american
crime novel on the screen.
And the writers they brought on to help them
do this came, not from the world of television,
but from the literary scene.
Novelist Denis Lenhane, George Pelacanos,
and Richard Price would all become critical
parts of the writing teams.
Authors who didn’t have much experience
writing for TV, but who were all well versed
in Urban Crime-Fiction.
And when Simon and Burns expanded the show
to subjects they didn’t feel they knew as
well, they brought in people who did.
Rafael Alvarez, another Baltimore journalist,
joined the writing team bringing his knowledge
of the Baltimore docks for season 2.
William F. Zorzi, a Political journalist in
Baltimore, joined to help write a lot of the
political story that starts in season 3.
With their experience as authors and journalists,
these writers brought to the show a greater
expectation for the audience.
They required a level of attention from the
viewers of the wire, not normally demanded
by television shows, but a level a step closer
to the level of attention you have to apply
to reading a book.
[s1e5 25:30]
This expectation of attention allowed the
writers to include many blink-and-you’ll
miss it details.
Blink and You’ll Miss It.
Here’s an example [s2e3 13:50] of the type
of quick and subtle storytelling you’ll
encounter in The Wire.
This scene from Season 2 shows Omar doing
reconnaissance for a stickup location, while
he is, he notices that two ladies are doing
the same thing.
And attentive viewer will see what’s happening
in the scene, and understand Omar’s recognition
of what’s going on.
But one glance at your phone, and you might
miss the entire 25 second, dialogue free scene.
This level of subtly is used frequently throughout
the show.
Like this scene from the second episode of
season 1, [s1e2 54:30] which begins to setup
Bodie as a character who is more on top of
things than his colleagues when he walks up
on a bunch of other drug dealers sleeping
on the job.
Very quick scenes, often won’t payoff until
episodes later.
One of the things that makes The Wire’s
storytelling so powerful, is that while characters
sometimes do express ideas directly, the most
important and central themes of the show are
all developed through this type of “show
don’t tell”, storytelling.
Season 1 is largely about establishing the
institutional similarities between the drug
dealers and the police officers, but no character
ever comes out and talks about this on the
show.
Instead the show relates the two by slowly
building up a collection of parallel scenes.
Like this scene that shows the police willing
to bend the rules [s1e9 38:14] while a few
scenes later we get an example of gang members
adhering closely to their rules [s1e9 53:50].
These two simple scenes progress the plot,
but more importantly they’re juxtaposition
shows us how both institutions have rules
for themselves, but that the motivations around
following those rules lead to different behavior
within the institutions.
These types of parallels are also used to
show the similarities between individuals.
Gang members need a judge to mediate their
differences, just like detective McNulty and
his wife.
Over time this collection of mirrored scenes
accumulates to showcase the similarities in
these different institutions, and how individuals
behave differently within them.
It creates a powerful argument, one that appears
to the viewer as self-evident through the
experience of watching the show.
But it wasn’t just the writing team’s
experience as writers that made the show what
it is, they utilized the team’s experience
as actual teachers, journalists, police officers
to create one of the most realistic fictional
shows that’s ever been put on TV.
A Man Must Have A Code: The Commitment to
Realism
David Simon and Ed Burns had an extreme level
of commitment to realistically portraying
Baltimore and the institutions within the
city.
Let’s look at the steps they took to make
sure they portrayed the character of the city
as accurately and realistically as possible.
Their backgrounds as a journalist and investigator
played a role in their approach to writing.
When they came up against a subject that they
didn’t know inside and out, they conducted
extensive research.
Whether you’re talking about the interviews
with dozens of stevedores, immigration officials,
port personnel, customs inspectors and steamship
agents that were conducted before writing
about the ports in season 2.
Or the extensive interviews and ongoing relationships
with Melvin Williams, real life Baltimore
drug king, who reformed after a long stint
in prison.
They clearly weren’t willing to write about
topics they hadn’t experience first hand
without extensive research.
And the commitment to realism extended beyond
the writing staff to the cast who often went
to great lengths to accurately portray the
lives their characters represented.
Andre Royo, who played Bubbles, the show’s
beloved heroin junkie said: “We were inspired
by the city of Baltimore, by the people in
Baltimore, of how these characters were supposed
to live and be portrayed.”
His portrayal of a junkie was so refined,
he was once chased of set by the show’s
security, who thought he was a real addict,
and was once handed drugs on the street by
another addict, who mistook Royo for the real
deal.
While Simon and Burns both insist that no
character is a direct correlation to a person
in real life, almost no character exists on
the wire that doesn’t have elements of one
or more real life people.
Bubbles was inspired in part by a long standing
informant of Ed Burns, Avon Barksdale and
Stringer Bell were both informed by actual
drug dealers like Mevlin Williams.
Williams would actually go on to take a role
in The Wire as the Deacon.
He was just one among many Baltimore locals
who had roles in the show.
Notably Prop Joe, was played by, a Baltimore
native.
Felicia Pearson, who plays Snoop, came from
the life she ended up portraying on screen.
Simon and Burns often named characters after
real life inspiration.
The actual Jay Landsman, who this character
is named after, acts on the show, but despite
auditioning for the part he’s named after,
he didn’t land the role, and ended up playing
Lt. Mello.
Ed Norris, who plays a detective in the show
by the same name, was the actual Police Commissioner
of Baltimore for 2 years right before the
show aired.
Bunk Moreland, Tommy Carcetti, and many others
draw inspiration from real life counterparts,
surprisingly even Omar, perhaps the most stylized
regular character on the show, is a composite
of six different gun-slingers who made their
living sticking up drug dealers in Baltimore.
Not to mention the locals who filled out the
roles as extras.
The inclusion of those who lived and new they
life they portrayed wasn’t just a cosmetic
choice, they helped keep the show from straying
into the realm of fantasy.
Steve Earle, who plays Bubble’s Narcotic’s
Anonymous sponsor, and had real life experience
in NA, said that they were encouraged as a
cast, to speak up if something didn’t feel
right.
When a city plays such a vital role in the
story, you have to be sure that you’re accurately
portraying that place.
And when you watch The Wire, you can be sure
that what you’re seeing is actually Baltimore.
The show shot extensively on location.
Row houses like these, were often cleaned
out, and re-dressed to look the same, but
with fake dog poop, needles, and broken drug
vials instead of the real thing.
Those from Baltimore who worked on the show
were often struck by how real, the portrayal
of the city was.
Laura Schweigman a Script Supervisor on the
show said about the opening scene: “I see
this when I drive around in Baltimore.
It was sad, but it was, at the same timer,
amazing, how real it felt, how real it looked.”
Fredo Star, who played Bird a drug dealer
in season one relates: “This is very real
out here…
… When I got thrown on the floor in one
of the scenes… ...glass was by my face.
It was like, “Hold up, let’s shoot the
glass.”
It was real.”
And it wasn’t just about making Baltimore
look like Baltimore.
West Baltimore looks like West Baltimore,
and East like East.
In a scene like this one, where street names
come into play.
The names and locations used are accurate,
to the extent that you can actually map out
the chase.
Frequent episode director and producer Joe
Chappelle recalls: “...when they would write
something and it was on a corner, whatever
the street corner was, we would shoot on that
corner.
It wasn’t like we go to a fun location and
put up fake signs.
We’d go to that specific corner.”
The Production
The commitment to realism extend into the
show’s style itself.
The Wire never utilizes a score, except in
a few select cases, all music in the show
comes from a source within the world.
But any hole left by score is filled by expertly
used sound design which helps to reinforce
the emotion of the story, and allows the city
to be a non-stop presence audibly in the show.
Use of diegetic music in the show is often
brilliant.
Like this chase scene, where the music in
playing Hurc’s car, and how it cuts in and
out, is used for comedic effect.
The shows cinematography exemplifies the same
ethos.
Committed heavily to a naturalistic approach,
without resorting to a documentary stylization,
the visuals manage to be striking and beautiful,
but always serving the locations and characters,
and rarely calling attention to itself.
Conclusion
The Wire’s story is undeniably political.
But the way it goes about telling that story,
through its commitment to realism, and by
painting a portrait of it’s themes and of
the institutions through a collection of individual
stories, keeps it from being propagandistic.
The show rarely prescribes a solution, and
seeks mostly to illustrate the problems, very
real ones.
Problems that continues unresolved to this
day.
The Wire is not a cop show.
There’s isn’t a simple good guys and bad
guys dichotomy.
We’re introduced to bad police doing the
right thing for the wrong reasons, and gang
members who seem to have just as much heart
as those on the side of the law.
Evil is not easily rooted out, we can barely
tell who isn’t tainted by malevolence.
The audience cannot root for order to be restored,
because order itself is corrupt.
Those who are willing to buck against the
systems do so out of desperation, because
they see no future for themselves in those
systems.
In Part II I’ll explore these themes in
greater depth, and how the wire uses narrative
structure and other techniques to portray
them.
So if you enjoyed this video, make sure you’re
subscribed, and keep your eyes open for
part II.